so this is it to get brexit done as this
conference has repeated relentlessly
Boris Johnson's team has come up with a
mind-boggling ly complicated
arrangements to solve the puzzle of the
Irish border Johnson of course did his
best to make it sound entirely fair and
generous and today in Brussels we are
taping what I believe are constructive
and reasonable proposals which provide a
compromise for both side but he was
clear about his motivation we will allow
the UK whole and entire to withdraw from
the EU with control over our own trade
policy from the start
Johnson's problem remains that he wants
to cut the UK off from the EU at its
border with Ireland for reasons of trade
but he wants to keep the border open for
reasons of politics his solution is to
try to have a bit of both creating two
borders one inside islands and one
between its and the UK mainland the hard
border in islands would break the law
yet Johnson said it was the UK's best
last and final offer
the alternative is no deal and that is
not that come we want it is not an
outcome we seek at all but let me tell
you my friends it is an outcome for
which we are ready are we ready for it
yes we are
the Conservative faithful seemed to love
it but has an idea it is so convoluted
and unacceptable to Ireland and by
extension the EU that there was an
immediate assumption it had been
designed to fail clearing the way for
the UK to leave the EU with no deal at
all so it all feels like what you might
call a longshot but don't underestimate
just how much some European countries
want to get rid of what they see is the
British problem and as well as that the
Johnson plan involves kicking parts of
the Irish border issue for years down
the road and who knows what the world's
going to be like by then Johnson now has
to see if the UK parliament has any more
appetite for all this than the EU if it
all gets stalled out he will say he's
tried and everyone else is to blame the
question
then we'll be if he's still in control
of events
Lawrence Lee al Jazeera Manchester